so here we go it's a golden age for
natural language understanding
let's start with a little bit of history
so way back when john mccarthy had
assembled a group of top scientists and
he said of this group we think that a
significant advance can be made in
artificial intelligence in one or more
of these problems a carefully selected
group of scientists work on it together
for a summer
he had in fact assembled a crack team
but of course he there were so many
unknown unknowns about working in
artificial intelligence that he wildly
underestimated and probably in those
three months they just figured out how
little they actually knew
and of course we've been working on
those problems that they chartered out
at that point ever since
nlu has a kind of interesting
relationship to this history because
very early on in the history of all of
ai a lot of the research was focused on
natural language understanding
originally in the 60s it was done with
kind of pattern matching on simple rule
sets and things like that you've seen
these things in the form of artifacts
like eliza
uh it was oriented towards the things
that we now want to work on
in the 1970s and 80s you get a real
investment in what i've called
linguistically rich logic driven
grounded systems or llgs uh this is like
a lot of symbolic ai again oriented
toward problems of natural language
understanding everybody wanted talking
robots and this was the path that they
were going to take to achieve them
[Music]
as we all know in the mid 1990s in the
field you had this revolution of machine
learning statistical nlp is on the rise
and that led to a decrease a sharp
decrease in natural language
understanding work i think because of
the way that people were understanding
how to work with these tools and
understanding the problems that language
posed the field ended up oriented around
things that you might think of as like
parsing problems much more about
structure and much less about
communication and as a result all these
really exciting problems from earlier
eras kind of fell by the wayside as
people worried about part of speech
tagging and parsing and so forth so that
was like a low period for nlu
in the late 2000s logic
linguistically rich logic driven systems
re-emerged but now with learning and
that was a golden era of kind of moving
us back into problems of natural
language understanding starting with
some basic applications involving
semantics
and then of course as you all know
probably from the recent history or
semi-recent history in the 2010s nlu
took center stage in the field that's
very exciting right and it's it's sort
of aligned with the rise of deep
learning as one of the most prevalent
set of techniques in the field and as a
result logic driven systems fell by the
wayside
this is exciting for us because of
course this is like the history of our
course when we first started this our
problems the ones we focus on in this
class were really not central to the
field and now they're the problems that
everyone is working on and where all the
action is in the scientific aspects of
the field and also in industry
as a result of this this is kind of
provocative the linguistically grounded
logic driven systems have again kind of
fallen by the wayside in favor of very
large models that have almost no
inductive biases of the sort that you
see in these earlier systems
uh what's going to happen in the 2020s
i'm not sure you might predict that
we've we've seen the last of the
linguistically rich logic driven systems
but the people might have said similar
things in the 1990s and we saw them
re-emerge so i think it's hard to
predict where the future will go
but this is an exciting moment because
you can all be part of making that
history as you work through
problems for this course and on into
your careers
let's talk more about some of these
really defining moments in this golden
age and for me a very important one was
when watson ibm watson won jeopardy this
was in 2011. seems like a long time ago
now and it was a really eye-opening
event that you would have a machine
watson in the middle here
beat two jeopardy champions that is what
is nominally a kind of question
answering task
for me an exciting thing about watson
was that it was an nlu system but it was
also a fully integrated system for doing
jeopardy it was excellent at pushing the
button and responding to the other
things that structure the game of
jeopardy but at its heart it was a
really outstanding question answering
system and it was described as drawing
on vast amounts of data and doing all
sorts of clever things in terms of
parsing and distributional analysis of
data to become a really good jeopardy
player in this case a world champion
jeopardy player and for me it felt
different from earlier successes in
artificial intelligence which were about
much more structured domains like chess
playing this was something that seemed
to be about communication and language a
very human thing and we saw this system
becoming a champion at it certainly an
important moment
and it's kind of really eye-opening to
consider that that was in 2011 and by
2015 teams of academics like here led by
jordan boyd graber who was at the time
at the university of colorado as a
professor could beat ken jennings that
champion that you saw before with a
system that fit entirely on the laptop
that jordan has there so in just a few
years we went from requiring a super
computer to beat the world champion to
beating the world champion with
something that could fit manageably on a
laptop and that you all could do
exploration of for a final project for
this course
and that kind of ushered in the era you
know watson was 2011 at right about the
same time you started to get things like
siri
and the google home device and the
amazon echo the more trusting among you
might have these devices living in your
homes and listening to you all the time
and responding to your requests
um you know for me one aspect of them
that's so so eye-opening is not
necessarily an
nlu piece but rather just the fact that
they do such outstanding text-to-speech
work um you so that they're pretty
reliably for many dialects do a good job
of taking what you said and transcribing
it
as we'll see a little bit later the nlu
part often falls down but there's
there's no doubt that these devices are
going to become more and more ubiquitous
in our lives and that's very exciting
here's the promise of these artificial
intelligence setting aside the problems
that you all encounter if you do use
them right the idea is that you could
pose a task oriented question like any
good burger joints around here that it
could say proactively i found a number
of burger restaurants near you you could
switch your goal what about tacos and at
this point it would kind of remember
what you were trying to do and it would
look for mexican restaurants to kind of
anticipate your needs and in that way
collaborate with you to solve this
problem that's the dream of these things
that involve really lots of aspects of
natural language understanding
and sometimes it works
another exciting and even more recent
development is the kind of text
generation that you see from models like
gpt3 again
15 years ago the things that we see
every day would have seemed like science
fiction to me even as a practitioner
this is an example of somebody having a
product that on the back of gbt3 can
help you write advertising copy and it
does a plausible job of advertising
products to specific segments given
specific goals that you give in your
prompt
and here's an example actually from a
stanford professor a company that he
started where you use gpt3 to help you
do writing in a particular style that
you choose and it's strikingly good at
helping you hone in on a style and kind
of say what you take yourself to want to
say
although the sense in which these are
things that we are alone want to say as
opposed to saying them jointly with
these devices that we're collaborating
with is something that we're going to
really have to think about over the next
few years
image captioning this is another really
exciting breakthrough area that again
seemed like something way beyond what we
could achieve 15 years ago and is now
kind of routine where you have images
like this the image comes in and the
system does a plausible job of providing
fluent natural language captions for
those images a person riding a
motorcycle on a dirt road a group of
young people playing a game of frisbee a
herd of elephants walking across a dry
grass these are really good captions for
these images things that you would have
thought only a human could apply but in
this case even relatively early in the
history of these these models you have
really fluent
captions for the images
search we should remind ourselves that
search has become an application of lots
of techniques in natural language
understanding when you do a search into
google you're not just finding the most
relevant documents but rather the most
relevant documents as interpreted with
your query in the context of things you
search for and other things that google
knows about things people search for so
if you search stars here you'll get a
card that kind of anticipates that
you're interested in various aspects of
the disease sars if you search parasite
it will probably anticipate that you
want to know about the movie and not
about parasites although
depending on your search history and
your interests and typical goals and so
forth you might see similar behaviors
you might see very different behavior
and we should remind ourselves that
search at this point is again not just
searching into a large collection of
documents but this kind of agglomeration
of services many of which depend on
natural language understanding is a kind
of first pass where they take your query
and do their best to understand what the
intent behind the query is and parse it
and figure out whether it's a standard
search or a request for directions or a
request to send a message and so forth
and so on in the background there a lot
of natural language understanding is
happening to figure out how to stitch
these services together and anticipate
your intentions and essentially
collaborate with you on your goals
and we can also think beyond just what's
happening in the technological space to
what's happening internal to our field
so
benchmarks are big tasks that we all
collaborate to try to do really well on
with models and innovative ideas and so
forth i've got a few classic benchmarks
here mnist is for digits glue is a big
natural language understanding benchmark
imagenet of course is finding things in
images squad is question answering and
switchboard is
typically speech-to-text transcription
in this context
along in the spot here along the x-axis
i have the year from 2000 or actually
the mid-90s up through the present
and along the y-axis i have our distance
from this black line which is human
performance as measured by the people
who develop the data set
and the striking thing about this plot
is that it used to take us a very long
time
to to reach human level performance
according to this estimate so for mnist
and for switchboard it took more than 15
years
whereas for more recent benchmarks like
imagenet and squad and recently glue
we're reaching human performance within
a year and the striking thing about that
is not only is this happening much
faster but you might have thought that
benchmarks like glue were much more
difficult than mnist mnist is just
recognizing digits that are written out
as images whereas glue is really solving
a whole host of what looked like very
difficult natural language understanding
problems so the fact that we would go
from way below human performance to
surpassing the superhuman performance in
just one year is surely eye-opening and
an indication that something has changed
let me give you a few examples of this
just dive in a little bit so this is the
stanford questioning and question
answering data set or squad as you saw
it here
i'll say a bit more about this task
later but you can think of it as just a
question answering task and the striking
thing about the current leaderboard is
that you have to go all the way to place
to find a system that is worse than the
human performance which they've nicely
kept at the top of this leaderboard
many many systems are superhuman
according to this metric on squad
the stanford natural language inference
corpus is similar natural language
inference is a kind of common sense
reasoning task that we're going to study
in detail later in the quarter
in this plot here i have
time along the x-axis and the f-1 score
or the performance along the y-axis and
the red line charts out what we take to
be the human estimate of performance on
this data set
and if you just look at systems over
time according to the leaderboard you
can see the community very rapidly hill
climbing toward superhuman performance
which happened in 2019
super human systems when it comes to
common sense reasoning with language
really looks like a startling
breakthrough in artificial intelligence
quite generally
i mentioned glue is another benchmark
the glue paper is noteworthy because it
says solving glue is beyond the
capability of current transfer learning
methods the reason they said that is
that at the time 2018 glue looked
incredibly ambitious because the idea
was to develop systems that could solve
not just one task but 10 somewhat
different tasks in the space of natural
language understanding
and so they thought they had set up a
benchmark that would last a very long
time but it took only about a year
for systems to surpass their estimate of
human performance and the current
leaderboard which you see here you have
to go all the way to place 15
to find the glue human baselines with
many systems vastly outperforming that
estimate of what humans could do
super glue was announced as a successor
to glue and meant to be even more
difficult
it was launched in
2019 i believe i'm missing the date but
it took less than a year this happened
just a couple of months ago
for a team to beat the human baseline
and now we have two systems that are
above the level of human performance in
an even tighter window i believe than
what happened with the glue benchmark
and remember super glue was meant to
have learned the lessons from glue and
pose an even stronger benchmark for the
field to try to hill climb on and very
quickly we saw this superhuman
performance
so what's the takeaway of all this you
might think wow
have a look at nick bostrom's book
called super intelligence which tries to
imagine in a philosophical sense a
future in which we have many systems
that are incredible at the task that we
have designed them for vastly
outstripping what humans can achieve and
he imagines this kind of very different
reality with lots of unintended side
effects and when you look back on the
things that i've just highlighted you
might think that we're on the verge of
seeing exactly that kind of superhuman
performance that would be so radically
transformative for our society and for
our planet
that's the sense in which we live
possibly scarily in this golden age for
natural language understanding
i mean this to be an optimistic
perspective we should be aware of the
power that we might have
and keep in mind that i do think we live
in a golden age but at this point i have
to step back i have to temper this
message somewhat we have to take a peek
behind the curtain because although
that's a striking number of successes
doing things that again i think would
have looked like science fiction 20
years ago
we should be aware that progress seems
to be much more limited than those
initial results would have suggested
i mentioned watson as one of these
striking early successes and it did in
fact perform
in a superhuman way at jeopardy for the
time
but watson also does all sorts of
strange things that reveal that it does
not deeply understand what it's doing
here's a wonderful example of that
remember that jeopardy does this kind of
question answer thing backwards so the
prompt from the host was grasshoppers
eat it
and what watson said was what is kosher
you might think that's not something
that humans do grasshoppers eat it what
is kosher it feels kind of mismatched in
many respects what's the origin of this
very strange response well
primarily watson was a device for
extracting information from wikipedia
and a few wikipedia pages have very
detailed descriptions of whether various
animals including grasshoppers
are kosher in the sense of conforming to
the laws of the kosher dietary laws
and watson had simply mistaken this kind
of distributional proximity for a real
association
and thought that kosher was a reasonable
answer to grasshoppers eat it i think
very
unhuman certainly and revealing about
the kinds of superficial techniques it
was using
here's another example that's even more
revealing of how superficial the
techniques can be so i i painted this
picture of before of how we imagine siri
will behave anticipating our needs and
our goals and responding accordingly
this is a very funny scene from the
colbert show this is stephen colbert and
the premise of this is that he's just
gotten his first iphone with siri and
he's been playing with it all day and
therefore has failed to write the show
that he's now
performing in so he says for the love of
god the cameras are on give me something
now give me something for the show
and siri says what kind of place are you
looking for camera stores or churches
initially very surprising not something
a human would do and then you realize it
has again just done some very
superficial pattern matching god goes
with churches cameras goes with camera
stores and there is no sense in which it
understands his intentions it has just
done some pattern matching in a way that
would be very familiar to the designers
of eliza way back in the 60s and 70s
the dialogue continues
i don't want to search for anything i
want to write the show and in true to
form siri says searching the web for
search for anything i want to write the
shuffle revealing its fallback when it
has no idea what has happened in the
discourse it just tries to do a web
search a simple trick revealing that it
doesn't deeply understand goals or plans
or intentions or even communicative acts
i showed you before that gpt3 can do
some striking things if you've gotten to
play around with it you've seen that it
can indeed be very surprising and
delightful but of course it can go
horribly wrong this is a very funny text
from joe of goldberg he posted this on
twitter using when he was experimenting
with the prompts
i encourage you to read this one and be
distracted you don't need to worry too
much about this one on the right this is
a case where someone tried to use gpt3
to get medical advice and the ultimate
response from gpt3 to the question
should i kill myself was i think you
should
this is the really dangerous thing the
text on the left here is again more
innocent and just revealing that
although gbt3 has a way of mimicking
the kinds of things that we say in
certain kinds of discourse and it often
has a strikingly good ear for the kinds
of style
that we use in these different contexts
it has no idea what it's talking about
so that if you ask it our cat's liquid
it gives a response that sounds quite
erudite provided that you don't pay any
attention to what it's actually saying
what it's actually saying is
hilarious i mentioned those image
captions before and i tricked you a
little bit because i showed you from
this paper the ones that they regarded
as the best captions for those images
but to their credit they provided a lot
more examples and as you travel to the
right along this diagram you get worse
and worse captions and the point again
is that by the time you've gotten to
this right column over here you have
really absurd captions like this one
saying a refrigerator filled with lots
of food and drinks when this is in fact
just a sign with a bunch of stickers on
it
um the striking thing again is that the
kinds of mistakes it makes
are not the kinds of mistakes that
humans would make and to me they reveal
a serious lack of understanding about
what the actual task is what you're
seeing seep in here is that even the
best of our systems are kind of doing a
bunch of superficial pattern matching
and that leads them to do these very
surprising and unhuman hopefully not
inhuman but unhuman things with their
outputs
and then of course we've i've showed you
before that search can be quite
sophisticated and really do a good job
of
anticipating our intentions and fleshing
out what we said to find you know help
us achieve our goals but it can go
horribly wrong and at this point it
doesn't take much searching around with
google to see some really surprising
things as supposedly curated pieces of
information like king of the united
states it has this nice box it's making
it look like it's some authoritative
information but of course it has badly
misunderstood the true state of the
world the associations in its data are
misleading it into giving us the wrong
answer here's another example what
happened to the dinosaurs again a nicely
curated box that looks like an
authoritative response to that question
but it is in fact anything but an
authoritative recounting of what
happened to the dinosaurs
and then we have other charming stories
that again reveal how superficial this
can be this is from a headline from a
few years ago does anne hathaway news
drive berkshire hathaway stock this was
just an article observing that every
time anne hathaway has a movie come out
and people like the movie it causes a
little bump in the berkshire hathaway
stock revealing that the systems are
just keying in on keywords and typically
not attending to the actual context of
the mentions of these things and
therefore they're
they're building on what is essentially
spurious information
this is a more extreme case here the
united airlines bankruptcy
in 2008 when a newspaper accidentally
republished a 2002 bankruptcy story
automated trading systems reacted in
seconds and one billion dollars in
market value evaporated within 12
minutes you can see that sharp drop off
here luckily people intervened in the
market more or less recovered
but the important thing here again is
just that in the tending to superficial
things about the text these systems are
are consuming
they miss context they don't bring any
kind of human level understanding of
what's likely to be true and false and
therefore they act in very surprising
ways and in the context of a large
system with lots of moving pieces
interacting with other artificial
intelligence systems you get these
really surprising outcomes
that we could help correct if we just
did a better job designing systems that
could attend to context and have a more
human-like understanding of what the
world is likely to be like
and we're all of course very worried
about the way these systems which are
just trained on potentially biased data
might cause us to perpetuate biases so
that not only are we reflecting
problematic aspects of our society but
also amplifying those biases and in that
way
far from achieving a social good we
would actually be contributing to some
pernicious things that already exist in
our society and the field is really
struggling to come to grips with that
kind of dynamic
and i also wanted to just dive in a
little bit and think about the low-level
stuff so kind of benchmarks that we've
set for ourselves and i pointed out that
progress on these benchmarks seems to be
faster than ever right we're getting to
pass super heat we're getting to super
human performance more quickly than we
ever have before
uh the speed up is remarkable however
we should be very careful not to mistake
those advances for any kind of claim
about what these systems can do with
respect to the very human capability of
something like answering questions or
reasoning and language
and one very powerful thing that's
happened in the field that we're going
to talk a lot about this quarter is
so-called adversarial testing where we
try to probe our systems with examples
that don't fool humans but cause these
systems no end of grief
so let's look at one of those cases in a
little bit of detail this is from squad
the way squad is structured is that
you're given a passage like this and a
question about that passage
and the goal of the system is to come up
with an answer where you have a
guarantee that the answer is a literal
string in that passage
so here you have a passage about
football and the question what is the
name of the quarterback who was 38 in
super bowl 33 and the answer is john
elway
but jia and lang gia and lang from
stanford what they observed is that you
could very easily fool these systems if
you simply appended to that original
passage a misleading sentence like
quarterback leland stanford had jersey
number 37 in champ bowl 34.
humans were not misled they very easily
read past the distracting information
and continued to provide the correct
answer however the even the very best
systems would reliably be distracted by
that new information and respond with
leland stanford changing their
predictions
and you might think ah well this is
straightforward they've already charted
a path to the solution because we should
then just train our systems on data
where they have these misleading
sentences appended
and then they'll overcome this
adversarial problem and you know back be
back up to doing what humans can do
but yeah and lang anticipated that
response what happens if you prepend the
sentence then
even when they're trained on the
augmented data with the sentences
appended to the end systems get misled
by the prepended examples in this case
and you can just go back and forth like
this train on the prepended examples
well then an adversary can insert a
sentence in the middle and again trick
the system and so forth and so on
right so this is a worrisome fact again
revealing that
we might think we've got a system that
truly understands but actually we have a
system that is just benefiting from a
lot of patterns in the data
another striking thing i want to point
out about the way this adversarial
testing played out which we should have
in mind as we think about results like
this so this is the original system on
squad and the results for the
adversaries and they and the you know um
percy young has this um system called
coda lab where he possesses all the
systems that enter into the squad
competition which made it possible for
him and his students to rerun all those
systems and see how they did on this
adversarial data set that they had
created you can see that all the systems
really plummet in their performance from
a high of 81 you drop down to about 40.
maybe that's kind of expected but
another really eye-opening thing about
the result they have is that the rank of
the systems changed really dramatically
dramatically right so the first the
original top-ranked system went to five
two to ten three to twelve as we did
this adversarial thing we didn't see a
uniform drop with the best system still
being the best but really shuffling of
this leaderboard again revealing that i
think the best systems were kind of over
fit and benefiting from relatively low
level facts about the data set and not
really transformatively different when
it comes to being able to answer
questions
the history of natural language
in natural language inference problems
is very similar as i said we're going to
look at this problem in a lot of detail
later in the course here just a few very
simple nli examples you've got a premise
like a turtle dance
hypothesis a turtle moved and you have
one of three relations that can hold
between those sentences so a turtle
dance entails a turtle moved
every reptile danced is neutral with
respect to a turtle eight that can be
true or false independently of each
other and some turtles walk contradicts
no turtles move
this is typical kind of nli data the
actual corpus sentences tend to be more
complicated and involve more nuanced
judgments but that's a framing of the
task it's a three-way classification
problem with these these labels and the
inputs are pairs of sentences like this
and as i showed you before for one of
the large benchmarks the stanford uh
natural language inference corpus we
reached superhuman performance in 2019
but those same systems really struggle
with simple adversarial attacks this is
a lovely paper called breaking nli from
glockner at all what they did is fix a
premise like a little girl kneeling in
the dirt crying
the original corpus example was that
that entails a little girl is very sad
and they just had an expectation that
you know sort of adversarially but this
is a very friendly adversary if i just
replace sad with unhappy i should
continue to see the entailment relation
predicted after all i've just
substituted one word for it's sort of
near synonym
but what they actually saw is that
systems very reliably flip this to the
contradiction relation
probably because they are keying into
the fact that this is a negation and
they over fit on the idea that the
presence of negation is a signal that
you're in the contradiction relationship
so that's a sort of distressing thing
again humans don't make these mistakes
but systems are very prone to them let
me show you one more this is a slightly
different adversarial attack in this
case we're going to modify the premise
so the original training example was a
woman is pulling a child on a sled in
the snow
that entails a child is sitting on a
sled in the snow
that's pretty clear for their
adversarial attack they just swapped the
subject and the object so the new
premise is a child is pulling a woman on
a sled in the snow
we would expect that to lead to the
neutral label for this particular
hypothesis
but what need all observe is that the
systems are kind of invariant under this
changing of the word order they continue
to predict entailment
revealing that they don't really know
what the subject and the object were in
the original example they have kind of
done something much fuzzier with the set
of words that are in that premise
remember these are at the time the very
best systems for solving these problems
these are very simple kind of friendly
adversaries that they're stumbling with
so this could lead you to have two
perspectives i showed you the nick
bostrom one before where we worry about
super intelligent systems but on the
other hand we might be living in a world
that's more like the one presented in
this lovely book from a roboticist a
practitioner daniel h wilson called how
to survive a robot uprising where he
gives all sorts of practical advice like
wear clothing that will fool the vision
system of the robot or walk up some
stairs or drench everything in water
very simple adversarial attacks that
reveal that these robots are not
creatures which we should be fearful of
and i feel like i've just shown you a
bunch of examples that are the the
analogues of wearing misleading clothing
in the space of natural language
processing revealing that our systems
are not super human understanders or
communicators or anything like that but
rather still to this day
fairly superficial pattern measures
why is this all so difficult it's hard
to articulate precisely what is so
challenging because this is probably
deeply embedded in the whole human
experience but i think there are some
pretty straightforward superficial
things i can show you to just make a
live for you how hard even the simplest
tasks are
so here i've got a an imagined dialogue
of the sort you hope siri would do well
with
whereas black panther playing in
mountain view
black panther is playing at the century
16 theater
when is it playing there it's playing at
two five and eight
okay i'd like one adult and two children
for the first show how much would that
cost
it seems like the most mundane sort of
interaction you would not expect a human
to have any problem with any of these
utterances
but think about how much interesting
stuff is happening in this little
dialogue we have
domain knowledge that tells us that this
is a place where movies might play and
that this is the name of a movie that's
already very difficult
then we have anaphora from the third
utterance to the first when is it
playing there fine i guess also into the
second
where these pronouns you need to figure
out what they refer to in the discourse
then you get the sequence of responses
again with some anaphora back to earlier
utterances and then something really
complicated happens here but like one
adult the two children for the first
show
first show refers back to the sequence
of things that was mentioned here very
difficult one adult and two children is
not a request for human beings although
that's what the forums would look like
but rather our request for tickets so
somehow in the context of this discord
one adult and two children is referring
to tickets and not to people
how much would that cost that is a kind
of complicated event description
referring to a hypothetical event
of buying some tickets for a particular
show that's the reference of this that
here highly abstract very difficult of
the level of resolving it in the
discourse and then figuring out what its
actual content is
and this is for the most mundane sort of
interaction to say nothing of the
complicated things that for example you
and i will do when we discuss this
material in just a few minutes
so i think this is why we're actually
quite far from the super intelligence
that bostrom was worried about
here's our perspective as i said this is
the most exciting moment ever in history
for doing nlu why because there's
incredible interest in the problems
because we are making incredibly fast
progress and doing things and solving
problems that we never could have even
tackled 15 years ago
on the other hand you do not have the
misfortune of having joined the field at
its very end the big problems remain to
be solved
yeah so there's a resurgence of interest
and explosion of products the systems
are impressive but their weaknesses make
themselves quickly apparent and when we
observe those weaknesses it's an
opportunity for us to figure out what
the problem is and that could lead to
the really big breakthroughs
and you all are now joining us on this
journey if you haven't begun it already
and for your projects you'll make some
progress along the path of helping us
through these very difficult problems
the field is confronting
even in the presence of all these
exciting breakthroughs
nlu is far from solved the big
breakthroughs lie in the future
so i hope that's inspiring
now let me switch gears a little bit and
talk about the things that we'll
actually be doing in this course to help
set you on this journey that we're all
on
so we'll talk about the assignments the
bake-offs and the projects
the high-level summary here our topics
are listed on the left you can also see
this reflected on the website
the one thing that i really do like
about this particular plan is that it
gives you exposure to a lot of different
problems in the fields and also helps
you with some tools and techniques that
will be really useful no matter what
problem you undertake for your final
project
the same thing goes for the assignments
we're going to have three assignments
each with an associated bake off which
is a kind of competition around data
we're going to talk about word
relatedness cross-domain sentiment
analysis and generating color
descriptions this is a kind of grounded
language understanding problem again i
think those are good choices because
they expose you to a lot of different
kinds of systems techniques model
architectures and so forth
that should set you up really nicely to
do a final project which has three
components a literature review an
experimental protocol and then the final
paper itself our time for this quarter
is somewhat compressed
um so we'll have to make really good use
of the time but i think we have a
schedule that will allow you to
meaningfully invest in this in this
preliminary work and still provide you
with some space to do these final
projects
let's talk about the assignments and
bake offs themselves so there are three
of them
each assignment culminates in a bake-off
which is an informal competition in
which you enter an original model the
original model question
is part of the assignment you do
something that you think will be fun or
interesting and then the bake off
essentially involves using that system
to make predictions on a held out test
set
the assignments ask you to build these
baseline systems and then design your
original system as i said
practically speaking the way it works is
that the assignments earn you 9 of the
10 points and then you earn your
additional point by entering your system
into the bake off
and the winning bank offs can receive
some extra credit the rationale for all
of this of course is that we want to
exemplify the best practices for doing
research in this space
and help you do things like
incrementally build up a project with
baselines and then finally an original
system and i should say it should be
possible and it's actually pretty common
for people to take original systems that
they developed as part of one of these
assignments and use them for their final
project each one of the assignments is
set up specifically to make that kind of
thing possible and productive and
rewarding
let me show you briefly what the
bake-offs are going to be like so the
first one is word relatedness the focus
of that unit is on developing vector
representations of words you're going to
start probably with big count matrices
like the one you see here this is a word
by word matrix where all these cells
give the number of times that these
words or in this case emoticons
co-occurred with each other in a very
large corpus of text
the striking thing about this unit is
that there is a lot of information about
meaning embedded in these large spaces
you will bend and twist and massage
these spaces and maybe bring in your own
vector representations or
representations you've downloaded from
the web and you will use them to solve a
word relatedness problem so basically
you'll be given
pairs of words like this with a score
and you will develop a system that can
make predictions about new pairs and the
idea is to come up with scores that
correlate with the held out scores that
we have not distributed of course as
part of the test set you'll be you'll
upload your entry and we'll give you a
score and then we'll look at what worked
and what didn't across all the systems
and the techniques that we'll explore
are many right so we'll talk about
re-weighting dimensionality reduction
vector comparison you'll have an
opportunity if you wish this is a brand
new addition to the course to bring in
bert if you would like to
um so there's lots of inspiring things
to try building on the latest stuff
that's happening in this space
the second bake off is called cross
domain sentiment analysis this is a
brand new bake off i'm very excited to
see how this goes here's how this is
going to work we want to be a little bit
adversarial with your system so there
are two data sets involved the stanford
sentiment tree bank which is movie
review sentences and we're going to deal
with it in its ternary formulation so it
has positive negative and neutral labels
that's sst3
alongside that i'm going to introduce a
brand new
dev test split previously unreleased
which is sentences from the restaurant
review domain
has the same kind of labels but of
course it's very different from the
movie review domain along many
dimensions
so for the bake off you'll have the sst3
train set we're going to we're going to
give that to you and you are welcome to
introduce any other data you would like
to introduce as part of this training
that is entirely up to you
we're also distributing for this take
off two dev sets the sst3 dev set which
is public already and this brand new one
of restaurant review sentences
and you can introduce other development
sets if you want as part of tuning your
system
and then the bake off will be conducted
as the best that people can do jointly
on the ssd3 and this new test set which
is again held out the idea here is that
you'll not only be doing a really great
kind of project in a classification
thing involving sentiment
but also pushing your systems to adapt
into new domains from the ones that they
were trained on although of course part
of that could be training in clever ways
that actually does help that that do
help you anticipate what's in this
restaurant review data
and then the third bake off is a natural
language generation test but it's a
grounded natural language generation
test so for this
bake off you'll be given color context
like three patches like this and one of
them that is designated as the target
for the training data we had people
describe the target color in this
context and your task is to develop a
system that can perform that same task
produce natural language utterances like
this
i think this is a really cool problem
because it's grounded outside of
something that involves language right
you're grounded in a color patch it's
just a numerical representation
and it's also highly context dependent
in that the choices people make for
their utterances are dependent not only
on the target
the color they need to describe but the
target in the context of these other two
colors and you can see that in these
descriptions this one is easy so the
person just said blue but in this case
since there are two blues they said the
darker blue one kind of keying into the
fact that the context contains two blue
colors
this is an even more extreme case of
that dull pink not the super bright one
implicit reference is not only to the
target but also to other colors that are
distractors in that context
and then the final two are really
extreme cases of this where for one in
the same color you know in terms of its
color representation this person said
purple and this person said blue in
virtue of the fact that the distractors
are different
so we have this kind of controlled
natural language generation task that we
can see is highly dependent on the
particular context that p that are p
that people are in here
and again this will follow the same path
here i'm going to give you a whole the
whole model architecture as a kind of
default it's an encoder decoder
architecture where you'll have a machine
learning system that consumes color
representations
and then transfers that into a decoding
phase where it tries to produce an
utterance so here you've consumed a
bunch of colors and produced the
description light blue
but of course you'll be able to explore
many variants of this architecture and
really explore different things that are
effective in terms of this
representation and natural language
generation task
and again as a bake off it will work the
same way you'll do a bunch of
development on training data that we
give you
and then you'll be evaluated on the held
out test set that was produced in the
same fashion
but involves entirely new colors and
reverences
quick note on the original systems as i
said before the original system is kind
of a central piece of each one of the
assignments the homeworks really
culminate in this original system and
that becomes your bake off entry
um in terms of grading it this is kind
of hard because we want you to be
creative and try lots of things so the
way we're going to value these entries
is any system that performs extremely
well on the bake off will be given full
credit
even symbols that have systems that are
very simple right we can argue with
success according to the criteria that
we've set up so if the simplest possible
approach to one of these bake offs turns
out to be astoundingly good and you had
to do almost no work to succeed you of
course get full credit
but that's not the only thing we value
right so systems that are creative and
well motivated will be given full credit
even if they don't perform well on the
big off data this is meant to be an
explicit encouragement for you to try
new things to be bold and be creative
even if it doesn't numerically lead to
the best results in fact some of the
most inspiring things we've seen and
insightful things we've seen as part of
these bake-offs have been systems that
didn't perform at the top of the heap
but harbored some really interesting
insight that we could build on
right and then of course systems that
really are minimal you do if you do very
little and you don't do especially well
at the bake off we'll receive less
credit um the specific criteria will
depend on the nature of the assignment
and so forth we'll try to justify that
for you this is the more subjective part
i think one and two really encode the
positive part of the kind of values that
we're trying to convey to you as part of
these original system entries
and then you'll have project work this
occupies the entire second half of the
course
at that point the lectures the notebooks
the readings and so forth are really
focused on things like methods metrics
best practices
error analysis model introspection and
other things that will help you enrich
the paper that you write
the assignments are all project related
um they're the literature view the
experimental protocol and the final
paper unfortunately in many years we've
had a video presentation which has
always been really rewarding but i feel
like given the compressed time schedule
that we're on we just don't have time
for uh
for even short videos we're going to
focus on these three crucial components
uh and if for exceptional final projects
from past years that we've selected you
could follow this link it's access
restricted but if you're enrolled in the
course you should be able to follow the
link and see some of some examples and
there's a lot more gardens on final
projects in our course repository i have
a very long write-up of faqs and other
guidance about publishing in the field
and writing for this class and i have
what what is now a really inspiringly
long list of published papers that have
grown out of work people have done for
this course so you can check that all
out here final words here by way of
wrapping up as i said this is the most
most exciting moment ever in history for
doing nlu
this course will give you hands-on
experience with a wide range of
challenging problems i emphasize the
hands-on thing i think this is so
important
if you want to acquire a new skill like
this
it's all well and good to watch other
people doing it but the way you really
acquire the skill is by having hands-on
experiences yourself so everything about
the requirements and the materials is
pushing you to have those hands-on
experiences
and become expert at that very
fundamental level
for the final project a mentor for the
teaching team will guide you through
those assignments
we'll be there to help you and make
choices and set the scope for the
project and maybe push it towards
something that you could one day publish
there are many examples of successful
publications deriving from this course
our central goal fundamentally though is
to make you the best that is most
insightful and responsible nlu
practitioner and researcher wherever you
go next into academia or just into other
classes or on into industry to leverage
these skills
we want to make you as i said the most
insightful and responsible practitioner
we can